dass also das live statement der
kanzlerin jetzt gerade über die
lockerungen paul fast doch bitte einmal
noch für uns zusammen was jetzt gerade
in dieser pressekonferenz alles gesagt
worden ist wurde sehr viel gesagt es war
eine sehr lange pressekonferenz mit
allen dreien zum einen die beschlüsse
über die wir schon vorher gesprochen
haben was in dieser runde beschlossen
worden ist
da geht es um die spielplätze und die
frage dass diese unter auflagen eben
wieder geöffnet werden können es geht um
gottesdienste die wieder möglich sind
unter anderem das waren eben diese
kleinen schritte von denen wir
gesprochen haben die großen
entscheidungen sondern im sechsten
fallen da wird es dann auch um schulen
kitas möglicherweise restaurants geben
gab es denn überhaupt eine überraschung
ja zu dieser pressekonferenz nein es
gibt keine überraschung was jetzt
öffnungen oder öffnungen angeht man muss
aber sagen schon überraschend war wie
eindeutig die kanzlerin bei ihrer linie
geblieben ist sie hat wieder gewarnt
sie hat eigentlich auch gedroht muss man
sagen denn sehr konkret gesagt dass man
einig sei wenn neuinfektionen wieder
ansteigen sollten das sozusagen die
maßnahmen wieder hochgefahren werden
könnten und sie hat beim blick auf die
wirtschaft gesagt natürlich habe sie das
im blick aber generell würde der
weltwirtschaft auch das am besten helfen
wenn wir dann nicht wieder zurück gehen
müssten also sie meint der wirtschaft
würde jetzt am besten geholfen wenn
sozusagen die die maßnahmen nur langsam
gelockert werden und damit man nicht
gefahr läuft wieder zurück in einen
totalen shutdown geht also ich fand ihre
rhetorik doch erstaunlich also sie
bleibt sozusagen bei ihrem kurs den sie
von anfang an gefahren hat ein satz der
mir vor allem im gerichtsgebäude ist es
markus söder über die kanzlerin er hat
gesagt sie ist die tatsächlich die
internationale stimme der vernunft was
hältst du von diesem satz ja markus
söder ist natürlich eigentlich fast noch
eine spur härter als die kanzlerin auch
in seiner rhetorik von daher sind sie
sich da sehr einig und natürlich stimmt
ist insofern wenn man international die
fallzahlen betrachtet wenn man allein
auf die gesundheitlichen statistiken
geht da wissen wir ja
dass selbst die washington post positiv
zum beispiel für die kanzlerin berichtet
hat aber wir reden eben jetzt langsam
nicht mehr nur über die statistiken zur
krone sondern auch darüber wie hoch die
arbeitslosigkeit steigen könnte
und das ist eine ganz andere debatte
vielen dank ihr paul spätestens am 6
stehen wir dann auf jeden fall wieder
hier und gucken wie die lockerungen dann
aussieht